so if you were to trace a single moment
or the race in virginia change we
thought well this isn't really what we
expected that date would be september
28th that's when terry mcauliffe
announced in public that actually he has
full control of your kids you have no
right to determine what they learn in
school watch
i don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach you know
i get really tired of everybody running
down teachers i love our teachers and
what they have done through covid these
are real heroes that deserve our respect
so we have spent last night and tonight
telling you why we think glenn younkin
won which is an amazing feat if you ask
anybody who covers this stuff for a
living last year is glenn younkin going
to be the next governor of virginia
precisely zero would have said yes not
nobody but he won anyone he won by a
real margin so we've told you why we
think he won
we're going to now ask him glenn younkin
will be the next governor of the
commonwealth of virginia and we're
delighted to have him join us now glenn
yonkin thank you very much why do you
think you pulled off what i i think
anyone would agree was an amazing feat
last night
well tucker first of all thank you for
having me back and and uh this campaign
stopped being a campaign a while ago and
it became a movement and yes it all
started in loudoun county many many many
months ago
but
parents across virginia started to
recognize that they really didn't need
to have a important decisive role in
their children's education
and when they heard terry mcauliffe say
exactly what you just played that
parents don't have a role in their kids
education he wants to put government
between parents and their children
this ceased to be a campaign and started
to be a movement led by parents
and while the kitchen table issues that
are so important to all virginians low
taxes and safe communities and great
jobs continued to be very much front and
center education really did become the
top issue in this in this election but
you took it at one point i was really
struck by this you took it to a
spiritual level which i don't know if
what your advisors thought of this but
you bet you said flat out we are all
equal in the eyes of god that's the root
of our equality we're judged equally by
god because we're created by god what
and bless you for saying that because
it's true what did your advisors think
when you said that
well tucker i i i don't run everything
by my advisors it's what i believe
and it's one of the reasons why i got
into this race is because i think
there's a there's a moment where we need
to speak the truth and and at this time
i think so many people are trying to
divide us
and tell one group that they should be
different than another and it's time for
us to come together and i as i traveled
around this great commonwealth of
virginia that i feel so blessed to
represent going forward what i heard
from from folks from all walks of life
no matter where the no matter where they
are in life is that they were tired of
the divisiveness and it was time for us
to come together and here here we have
in our schools a moment to stop teaching
our children about their differences and
start teaching them about the things
that can bring us together and prepare
them for a great life and that's what
we're going to do in our schools when
i'm governor is get our kids ready to to
actually go reach after the virginia
promise that we're going to make
available to all kids in virginia
you've such a huge job i've never seen a
state move as quickly in one direction
as virginia has under the last two
governors do you i mean
are you ready for this your task ahead
well tucker we spent the whole day today
uh getting ready i mean we we got up and
went to work and uh this this is what we
have to do tucker i i'm i've been
trained to work in real people time not
government time and so we're already
getting ready to start moving and
everybody knows our day one plan is is
about getting taxes down and getting our
schools focused back on educating our
children making our communities safe and
getting our job machine crank back up
but i was really overwhelmed by the by
the broad support across the entire
commonwealth of virginia i mean we had
help from everybody we had a huge
support from the latino community you
know the president made a call and asked
everybody to get out and vote and we had
big turnout in southwest virginia we saw
parents turn out we were endorsed by the
hampton roads black caucus and we did
better in the minority communities than
i think any republicans done in a long
time this is how we bring people
together focused on these most important
issues and i just want to thank virginia
for hiring me to go to work for you and
i'm going to give it everything i got
we're all created by god it turns out
that's a message people like because
again it's true glenn young i really
appreciate your coming on tonight and
again congratulations on a remarkable
this is the moment when people say you
know enough so thank you
thank you tucker and i hope you have a
blessed night thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else